alright [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] ye no I'm
gonna [ __ ] the arrow over here cuz this
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] I see yes
Bob no big hockey pucks or arrows down
here it's [ __ ] amazing on the same
low there ok [ __ ] that's the only
way I ever go ever nice one black hole
already shut down the roof stuff you can
jump around the black hole I think you
can jump around a black hole
[Applause]
you pushed him into it stupid or that's
what you're supposed to do well I'm
taking that away what the door thank you
I don't want it there no other door the
roof okay just the door maybe Bob just
the door I'm in place anything in what
Bob does
[Laughter]
you guys check what did you do oh my god
we have two people that have been oh man
we got this we got it we got it
I think it probably just gives you more
points right wait
points oh oh no thank you Bob face
failure weight is still treating weight
just saying why is that there wait no no
it's fine
mark no you have to destroy the
platform's [ __ ] okay well that's
fine makes it a little even no Jack Jack
whoa oh [ __ ]
whoa oh the thorns kill you Oh Oh God
the [ __ ] ice [ __ ] guys no I don't
[Laughter]
what just make it a little harder can't
have this be too easy I destroyed the
thing blocking the goal there so it
should be a little easier to go Bob Bob
Bob listen where's gonna weed Bob you
got to stop him
that's a good point that's good but
barbed wire on the ground I got an idea
I got an idea No
Oh God okay do it alright fine Bob well
mark how do you enjoy your victory well
I I know that things are x or you better
die Jack you better fail and die good
luck what are you gonna do I don't know
I thought better of this way to go honey
no why honey you're all screwed you're
gonna die
have fun and death I got zero points
this is such [ __ ] I was gonna win
this is such [ __ ] there's there's a
question mark box
what is this speedrunners what we can
unlock either a new level new character
or skin or something might give a new
level maybe we shoulda done party mode
Oh what is that we need to get this box
okay whatever where's the box right here
I'm gonna put a platform to get to it
there I don't well they're for me [ __ ]
you I don't yeah go ahead get your box
to Jack it might be a skin for you or
something well might be a new level I
don't know I don't know what it is how
many levels are there in the game
I think there's two I haven't unlocked
it's helping I got the waterfall oh my
god
all right wolf it's gonna be like that
it's gonna be pleased I got a reason to
pull it up oh no Bob Bob you two back
Bob
God and up okay [ __ ] I'm trapped here no
you're not
[Laughter]
hahaha alright boys trapped oh my god
you can do it that I can do to make this
less possible Bob oh oh you were doing
that okay what what are you doing over
there
Bob honey oh my god
oh god why alright bye everybody
you're gonna get crushed awesome I
didn't even know that was gonna work but
yeah all of my theory is the water do
anything I wonder from here Bob pushes
you okay okay we're not gonna make it
too easy though make it a little
difficult you know a little challenge
here it'll be fine
it's good it's not too hard Wow does
look like happy wheels I was thinking
that yeah
good idea okay yeah oh yeah I'm gonna
put down a coin just because like like I
like this platform being up here so jump
on that Oh God that's nice
[Music]
I'm just adding a whole bunch of coins
first-come first-served oh that's not
fair okay I got what these coins do
nothing oh no they are attached to me I
got it get to the end [ __ ] [ __ ]
hockey yeah I'm not looking out for it
[Laughter]
I'm not confident in my jokes me alright
[Music]
what I'm sad
what what what what it's trying to make
it interesting what what Oh God the
pucks are below that I wouldn't block my
pucks pucks through my babies Jagga
saved your life
aren't you though why are you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I even put coins up there for you
morning I don't snort what I laugh but I
keep doing it you know what this honey
was good fun for anybody
none fun honey platform I put another
honey
I made another honey platform no my
honey my honey honey on it honey on that
one it's honey it shows this is honey
there is no no money no no Bob that's my
honey one there's honey there I saw no
honey it was honey there god damn it Bob
poor Jack always hits my traps oh hey I
spy for god oh no no there's no way this
is gonna happen
[Music]
oh man
so you think this part over here should
be easier mark yes please yes absolutely
yeah yeah I like how now you have to
destroy the platform's to destroy the
ice Bob honey I had to destroy the
platform I don't want mark to do his job
Bo for nonsense anymore good
[Music]
no wait somebody not please Jim I have
all God from the ashes comes back oh I
forgot to hit my sprint button
oh my god they're both ice [ __ ] on me we
really hate each other this is such
[ __ ] any more coins I haven't really
funny idea but it's gonna take more than
one round to execute I want to see if
this works
uh-huh Jack no Jack no no Jack trust me
it'll be hilarious for a question block
over there I'm helping Bob incentivize
[Laughter]
it was way away it was not there on my
screen no two people have made it to the
end
all right everyone ready for this this
is gonna be awesome how awesome Nick
what yes like we're supposed to I don't
want anyone to win I'm tied for first
right now what Bob what about me all
right ice be cool ice be cool [ __ ] you
so close Bob so close get up there you
were gonna get up there what we made it
oh you're gonna have to work together
bah-bah-bah-bah bah-bah-bah-bah hope
your body is blogging the arrows thank
you for the welcome
[Laughter]
why didn't I get trapped points for that
one
can I just attach can I attach this to
this idea aren't even winning and yet
we're all including me just putting down
more traps not gonna turn that one's
gonna block it from turning you just
ruined everything
oh I'll blow it up for you Bob he messed
it up upload yeah why don't I destroy
the one that wasn't on the honey because
it's not supposed to be on the honey
it's supposed to be on if it's not on
the honey it's just in a stationary spot
okay barbed wire on the saw blade I'm
overcome
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah validated by not so horse is the
one do we make it harder or possible
someone who makes it past that point a
gift okay that's that's acceptable
what holy [ __ ] a little bit of a gift
acceptable acceptable we'll take it I
guess all right and I just want to make
sure that no one does jumpy jumpy jump
eNOS here well they got a grater they
gotta go under you got to go under just
where's that there it is okay well the
coin didn't last
[Laughter]
okay thanks for having any fun all right
what's the top there yeah understand it
either of you launch the game right
[Music]